[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's up
Madison hello how we doing good I have a
question so I'm wondering if I should
sell my personal car and just use my
boyfriend's company car his personal car
to pay off some of my
debt you want to sell your car to use
your boyfriend's company
car correct I don't think that that's a
good idea this doesn't end well yeah cuz
what like this is where my mind goes I'm
going just say it what happens if you
get in an accident in your boyfriend's
company car which means the company's
paying for him to use it for work
Transportation so I have coverage
through his work we actually work for
the same company do you have coverage on
his vehicle or you have coverage because
you just work
there like you're listed on his vehicle
correct on both of them so his personal
car and his company car I have coverage
okay so it's it's completely
kosher yes and my car essentially is
just sitting in the driveway right now
and I I don't touch it so I don't know
if I'm losing money by it just sitting
there um I still owe on it so I'm still
making payments but I just I don't know
if it's beneficial to just have my car
sitting here and not use it or if I
should sell it I think that's different
I think that's inde depent from
him I'm more nervous about
you you're going to be very
exposed okay and I know and when I say
this you're gonna go not us it would
never happen no I know no I know I
understand but you know what I mean
that's why I wanted to ask yeah I I if
you're my sister or you're my daughter
or you're just one of my buddies who's a
woman I would tell you if he marries you
great yall make financial decisions
together and y'all go in and share share
a car and all that yeah if it's a
boyfriend I mean Jade and I would not
have jobs if every every well-laid plan
ended right and so you're you're selling
your car exposing yourself to him and
his company which happens to be your
company too that's just a lot of you are
hitching Your Wagon to some unsecure
horses and getting dragged into the wild
right that's that just makes me nervous
what's your car worth that's sitting in
the
driveway about about 9,000 9,000 is it
in it is it paid off or you have
payments on it still I have I'm still
making payments so that's my biggest
thing is I'm paying an insurance I'm
making my monthly payments and I'm not
using it and how much do you still owe
on it about 5,000 yeah I'm Gonna Keep it
I'd pay it off yeah keep it and pay it
off how quickly can you pay it off here
so that's that's kind of the second part
of this I have some debt and I just
don't know how to approach my debt and
what's the most important thing to pay
off first okay let's figure that out
what uh list your debts for me just as
however they come to mind okay so I have
credit card which is about 3,000 okay I
have um house so we actually have a
house so do you want me to include my
mortgage uh who's who's listed on the Lo
both of us both of you are listed on it
yes all right we'll get to that in a
minute all right um Madison Courthouse
this weekend yeah we'll deal with that
protect yourself yes okay what else and
then appliances we have about 4,000 oh
Lord okay keep going and then um my car
was about 5,000 and then I have medical
debt and that's a big one and I've I've
paid a lot of it down and that's about,
1500 now okay so it's only 1,500 okay
yeah um and then the mortgage just so I
know uh what is it it's about 1,900 a
month yeah but how much is it the total
oh total is is about 200,000 200,000
okay like John said how you guys need to
get married you're playing house just
just do it and this is not like for
religious reasons this is for you to
protect yourself legally because if it
hits the fan this is going to be so
messy and so crazy that you're
protecting yourself by making sure that
this is all legally wrapped up in a
marriage um does he have any
debt he does not he does not okay so
until you get married but you're getting
married this weekend um we're going to
list these debts and and I'm I'm I'm
laughing but I'm being serious like get
yourself the certificate go online and
do the certificate and then you guys
plan a party for later and have
champagne and have it fun but for now
let's get this legal stuff locked up is
there any reason that he would not want
to do that so when we graduated college
um we sat down and we had a conversation
and it really came down to what do we
want to do first and I'll be honest we
both agreed that we would rather go with
the house first because
of cuz we wanted to live somewhere so
our landlord actually um told us about
30 days before our lease was ending that
he was no longer going to be renting and
he was selling the house so we didn't
have much time to really find a place to
live so that's when we started looking
for houses and we lived with his parents
for a few months so you solved a 30-day
uhoh with a 30-year
commitment yes and that doesn't really
that still doesn't really answer my
question my question was if you said hey
I want to get married this weekend so
we're protecting both of our butts in
this marriage is there any reason that
he would not want to do that that was my
question I don't think so I think it's
more of just the traditional essence of
bust up tradition say y'all don't care
about tradition tradition tradition's
gone not those tradition you guys y guys
borrowed money on a dishwasher yall have
thrown tradition out the window
but I guess what I'm trying to get at is
I want to make sure that he understands
that we're not playing house forever and
yeah honestly legally you need to be
protected and you need to make him
understand that hey if this goes south
there is nothing that is going to um
there is no way that this is going to be
decided fairly because there's no
marriage here so if you guys break up
and you cheat on him or he cheats on you
or you just dislike each other you have
a house together and he can just up and
leave and leave you with that debt or
you can just up and leave and leave him
with that debt or he you know what I'm
saying there's so much tied up here's
what makes me scary here's what makes me
scared and know and we're we're
consciously leaning on the other side of
the Seesaw cuz you're on the happy side
oh my gosh look how great it's awesome
right we're on the other side if
something goes sideways in your
job if something goes sideways in your
relationship you don't and you have sold
your car and you're just driving around
town in his car you don't have a home
you don't have a car you don't have a
job and here's what's important about
that you know that risk and you and I'm
going to believe you that risk is very
very small but do you know what doesn't
know that risk profile you're amygdala
the part of your brain that is designed
to keep you safe all the time it knows
one tiny misstep and you are homeless
carless unsafe without groceries and
your body would be failing you if it let
you sleep all night in this current
situation your body would be failing you
if it let you have deep connected
intimate moments with your boyfriend
because it's trying to not
die and so when we talk about like dude
go do this now your whole body
goes and if it if the thought of getting
everything lined up so that you could
feel safe if that makes you feel more
anxious and more scared then you all go
see a pre-marriage counselor tomorrow
because y'all need to deal with that
reality you see what I'm saying right
yeah and so it's it's us loving you
because we just see the other side of
this this thing going sideways and no
one plans for that by the way nobody
plans for that and I wouldn't wish that
on you for one second I want this to
work out perfectly and I want it happily
ever after and all that stuff but woo
man you're exposed exposed exposed
exposed But to answer your money
questions we've just told you how to
handle your anxiety and your relational
questions once you get married this
weekend you guys are listing this debt
from smallest to largest and now you're
combining and getting after this
together right with your combined income
combined efforts your debt now becomes
his debt both of your paychecks now
become our paychecks both of your debt
becomes our debt and you guys move
through this and you process it together
if you're not going to get married if
you're like hey I don't care what you
guys say then you pay this off by
yourself and you need to look into a way
of getting one of your names off of that
mortgage all right and figure out how to
do that because I if you're not going to
get married you don't both need to be on
this deed